[Musik]
hast du ein auftrag für mich
irgendwo im kanton zürich wurde ein
verbrechen begangen
martin bolliger rückt aus ihr auftrag
vor ort spuren sichern
fortan ist meistens auch lange
vorbereitungszeit einen tatort wo man
sich gedanken macht das spiel dürfen ran
idee sich so mental vorbereiten wie
einfältig serviceauto talon den meistens
tausch panik lotte noch wenn wir ein
metalltor tisch und mal mit allen
rechten
[Musik]
unsere erste herausforderung an diesem
nachmittag aus der stadt zürich
herauszukommen
und weil sie kaum ist die go ahead damit
den dunkelblauen das ist stoff befestigt
finden mich dass wir mit den uns doch
unter harmlos aber sie meistens auftrag
war so geordnet wartet blaulichtfahrt
wenn's passiert polizei in brand
jetzt ist logisch unter kontrolle es
geht wirklich um die spurensicherung
die kantonspolizei zürich hat dieses
auto bereits vom tatort entfernt und in
eine garage gebracht wo es repariert
werden soll sobald die kriminaltechniker
in ihre arbeit abgeschlossen hat
es bringt da sitzt man sich das
fotografieren sind einfach über 60 namen
macher von tatort angetroffene situation
und anhand von der photonik man sich
erinnere und bürger also etwas zäh voran
und wenige plötzlich eine spur zum zum
tragen und oder zur diskussion steht
genau das ist für mich dass man im
nachhinein gemacht oder das ist schock
sie also folgt eine sind immer sehr sehr
wichtig kontrabass ihrem anruf möglich
sind wo man am tatort an onyx karen
bolik erhält ihre eindrücke nicht nur
fotografisch sondern immer auch
schriftlich fest
und dann kommt auch noch ein
wattestäbchen zum einsatz
damit können dna spuren gesichert werden
es ist schwierig wenn andere angelangt
wo das auto sichergestellt hand und die
wichtige spur weil deren unterem ruhe
und mitglied der such as pure da sind
also die täter selber das nachher
angelangt
rund 700 und kollege von mir hat noch
andere mögliche spuren gefunden tannheim
mit einer sachbeschädigung mit dem brand
ja auch so
ja auch etwas mit rein
situation heute morgen 87 jahren
gestorben also was man jetzt noch
gefunden haben die stunde der spanische
teil von den zweite auto gestoßen unter
dem auto und ich geschützt
und doch inter und was für spuren dass
man darf ihnen dabei bisschen sicherer
das ergebnis liefert
ich gehe aus erklärungen vielleicht
geht's motive branche durch thermisch
romero fall der schiene besser mm aber
nur gibt es nur dort wo emotional
belastend sind sehr viel eigentlich
verschrottet dort von mir könnt sind ja
emotional belastbares schicksal von
menschen seine hand
das einte die aber das aufstellen und
die andere wo zu unterbinden oder reich
betroffen sind die situation noch ist
unklar ob der brand in dieser tiefgarage
mit absicht gelegt wurde
die ermittlungen werden zeigen ob ihr
wirklich ein verbrechen vorliegt
[Musik]
irgendwo abgeschmolzen jetzt auch eine
undefinierbare
die chance sehr bedeckt mit ruß und so
heftige hätte nicht schwer ich dass mir
die möglichkeit ihr den ausfuhren nach
und brot das für die den extrem
erschwert so viel neues partikel dringen
aber ich muss mal probieren
pauli gemacht sich auf den rückweg ins
forensische institut mit dem sichern der
spuren ist ihre arbeit an diesem fall
noch lange nicht abgeschlossen
23 sind sie zufrieden mit dem satz das
beste machen können und das macht kein
wunder meisten davon versprechen nun
beginnt die büroarbeit beweisstücke
werden elektronisch erfasst protokolle
und berichte geschrieben
eine katze sei als kind ihres das
haustier gewesen erinnert sich bolliger
mehr war in einer wohnung nicht möglich
heute besitzen sie und ihre mann ein
haus mit großem umschwung im rafzerfeld
und halten unter anderem zwei autos eine
kleine heile welt sie habe da sehr
idyllisch ist das ein ausgleich zu ihrer
radtour über die fahrt dennis sowie den
ferien das feriengefühl rufe ich mich so
entspannt und einfach die ab streife der
alltag und und ist einfach schön das
privileg tor versuchslabors wohne und
tier und natur
das gehalt ist hart das ist üblich so
einfach gut tut
erholungsphasen seien wichtig in ihrem
job sagt sie
nicht nur physisch sondern auch im kopf
weit weg zu sein von tatorten
ihre freizeit verbringt sie gerne mit
ihrem mann den sie kennen lernte lange
bevor sie zur polizei ging
sie ist gelernte pharma assistentin und
arbeitete später als flight attendant
eigentlich ist das so
ich glaub ich wie viele andere sollen
ein jugendtraum
es ist wirklich so behandle andere ist
auch gemacht aber ich habe mich lange
studiert wie sagt war und den gemeinden
ich merkte stets dank ich probiere es
mit der aufnahmeprüfung und das hat
alles geklappt und dann habe ich die
polizeischule lang und wird den jemen
oder natürlich die richtige entscheidung
ihr mann findet sie sei eine
idealbesetzung der die fähigkeiten sind
von menschliche haar das sie spürte
weiter verfestigt dass andere menschen
sind dass sie mit sozialkompetenz hätte
und das bruchsichere der polizei und
auto grüßen programmatisch handele
gewisse situationen schnell handle
fokussiert handle und druck sehe ich das
grab von totalem enix dass sie das burka
mich hat einfach geschichten
interessiert behindert
ich liebe wähler wüssten was was ich und
ich denke dass man das
das hätte und ich denke es ist eher brav
nicht für jeder mensch natürlicher größe
grundvoraussetzungen muss mitbringen
was ist dort am morgen viele motivierte
zum geschäft versteht wird oder so keine
machen
nachdem sie kantonspolizisten geworden
war wechselte bohli ganz forensische
institut das die kantons und die
stadtpolizei zürich zusammen betreiben
zeit jährlich für die zentrale
puzzleteile zu löw
von verbrechen ist ein teilziel 52
dürfen ein wichtiger beitrag leisten
damit recht und unrecht frauen gar nicht
leiden wenn man zum beispiel von der
fingerabdrücke oder dna spuren plötzlich
ein name passt zu einer person wollen
frohe kunde den meistens gut irgendwo
wieder hätte ein stückchen volk kaum was
damit passiert
die person möglich der tat ist das ist
ja nun gesichert wenn man sport oder
nicht was denn passiert mit dem fall was
für den schuldspruch gesprochen wird
das nicht mit übernimmt sie das zum teil
interessieren
die einzelnen sachen show aber wenn ich
jetzt darüber alle immer wird genügend
nachfrage was ist da passiert das sind
ein gar nicht so genau ist neugierig
gucken auch hallo das ist doch ein
schuss nach vorn
unbekannte sind in eine bijouterie
eingebrochen bolide war am tatort einem
fall eröffnung im nachtrag vom letzten
und jetzt alles spur aber nicht gleich
system genau dokumentieren was ich für
spuren gesichert hat das ersichtliche
ist und dann entscheiden welche spuren
das ich nun auswerten oder genau wenn
sie ihren komitee nach spuren
schuhabdrücke noch gesichtet ja nie
fotografieren und das foto vom profiteam
wo das fotografierte ich habe ich die
spuren kann irgendwie verwachsen
[Applaus]
zunächst die spur nicht sicher etliche
mit verschiedenen spuren gesammelt hat
verletzte bremen ist im rallye dakar
sammler und den vergleichen
das machte mich spielt dann hängen die
delikte allenfalls erkennen was die
gleiche spur gekommen
vorne mit und hilft mir rauszufinden was
ist für markus fordern
foto sport also was ist heute für marca
sie aber dort nicht gefunden
der tv zuschauer ist anderes gewohnt
menschen sichern spuren und computer und
ihre datenbanken erledigen den rest
in der realität bleibt der mensch
offenbar zentral
also zählen natürlich genau das finden
aber es geht vielen shows spur aber
eigentlich sind und da kommen nicht so
ganz genau was ist wenn ich manchmal
auch für den abgleich von
fingerabdrücken gilt keine rötungen
computer sondern denken die menschen
maschine im 20
die erkennt dass weniger also es ist
eigentlich schön in 20 panzer toll
weiter so
aber das ist handarbeit und tochter
konzentrationen nach wie vor die medien
aber nur gerücht sind die futuristischen
apparate und methoden der forensiker
nicht spezielle lichter zeigen zum
beispiel ob auf einem beweismittel
fingerabdrücke und dna hinterlassen
wurden und ob sich eine weitere
auswertung also lohnt
wieder ein verbrechen im kanton zürich
karen bolliger hat piqué und wurde
aufgeboten
in diesem fall geht es um den einbruch
in eine geschäfts liegenschaft geld soll
verschwunden sein und vielleicht noch
mehr
weil viele spuren zu erwarten sind ist
bolliger heute mit einem kollegen
unterwegs
[Musik]
verbrecher hinterlassen nicht nur dna
und fingerabdrücke sondern auch
eindeutige werkzeugspuren auch die
können zum täter führen
kratzspuren und ein letztes entsprechen
zwar zu gut findet dazu ein anderes
frieren und es passt die stadtpolizei
zürich ist bereits vor ort und bringt
die kriminaltechniker auf die neuesten
stand
zwei personen sie und ist die kolleg
auto immer so genau
ich war jetzt nur interessant die
vielleicht politische schaffen
[Musik]
diese fordere kritiker spur
das ist der ort wo das endet und wo man
wirklich die spurensicherer wo es denn
zu ihrer person führt wo mit florian
cottbus oder muss er klarere grund die
sparte sammeln sind es und da fehlen mir
sicher dass man nie weiß was etwas
passiert hoffentlich schaffe und alles
ist noch gewachsen
die handtasche schaffe man verschiedene
tatort die mainzer konnten die
verschiedenen kollegen
jeden tag bieten uns genau die ist
wirklich ein anderer form anderer korpus
ist komplett und ringel um den tisch
klopfen und also es ist schon speziell
und die politischen weg
die spielen mit einer sprache wurde
privat
nein bis jetzt gott sei dank nicht
weiter der 1
würden sie denn die spule dort sein
versicherer oder würde sie kollegen ali
t ich glaube ich will jetzt selber
machen mini spuren sind ja sowieso dr
ich kenne mich aus am besten und weiß wo
fremde sind meine besten freunde mit
einer klage kommt aber ich weiß nicht ob
das legal ist
[Musik]
geht es nach teterow gottes spuren
hinterlässt dann seid jede hinterließ
spuren wie bei jedem schritt kate zahlen
ab und zu zahlen sind die tage von
dna-material und unsere aufgabe stehen
genau die spur zu finden wurden
das theater schafft führe also dauert
jedoch spuren aber am pfosten
da und ich sehe die genau die waren
spuren hat eine schule wieder einmal wie
gewohnt auf den stuhl mini theorie ist
dass da auf den stuhl vermutlich
geständig und versuchte von oben nichts
wissen
da ist wirklich viel betroffenen aus der
unterschicht die folie man den spuren
sichern
die tische der stuhl wies und dennis ist
schwierig das fotografieren und logisch
habe ich mich darauf
dank schlecht gestimmt also zweifach
dass die personenwaage plastisch auf dem
stuhl opfer gestanden
die spuren sind gesichert das geht
zurück ins büro und dann nach hause in
ihre idylle weit weg von all den
tatorten fc schonach limitierung das ist
schon das war sicher interessant ist
aber in jedem xii eine szene mit grund
dass wir so weitermachen wenn die heiko
mit der regel jährlich gar nicht viel
erlauben in sonic wie sie nicht dürfen
sie gar kris peeters der hand ich habe
oft gar nichts bedürfnis zeit ja es gibt
ja auch noch andere themen und sie zu
können